hi welcome to metaphysical milkshake i'm
maureen wilson and i am raine's co-host
reza aslan that's how it should be
rain's co-host but listen co-host i'm a
little worried about you
why well i just want you to know that
i'm always here to talk if you need a
shoulder to cry on okay well that's very
sweet and i'm touched by that but i'm
fine i'm i'm totally fine are you
are you really you poor pathetic sad
clown are you i don't i am not wait why
would you call me a sad club i am not a
sad clown well i read one of your tweets
the other day i thought it was hilarious
like lol
funny yeah that's cause i'm i'm a very
witty guy people know that i write funny
things well it is funny it's a little
too funny frankly and like all court
jesters you're clearly screwed up inside
okay all right i'm not screwed up inside
i know what you're doing just stop wait
wait wait you don't think i know what
that is i'm one of the funniest
character actors since david schwimmer
by sheer accident
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
i'm sorry david schwimmer
who wrote this stuff
who's this this is this is terrible this
script we're reading off this banter was
written by our producer dj lubell dj get
over here hi dj tj hi rayne hi reza did
you write this yeah i i i did write it
and i got to be honest i don't i think
it was the performance that quite
frankly wasn't funny are you kidding me
people don't know this about our
producer dj lubell apparently you you
were what some kind of funny person in
the previous life is that is that true
yeah i mean listen i've written for a
bunch of comedy shows i've sold a couple
pilots i like to think i'm a funny
person this is really interesting
because i've always for some reason
thought of you as a sad person
like a sad clown
i didn't say sad clown but yeah are you
a sad clown i mean some of my com some
of my conversations with you guys is
self-deprecating i mean i make fun of
myself a little bit but no i'm overall
pretty happy person i don't know why you
would
say that well look this is actually i
mean
it's okay tj like if you
like you don't have to be embarrassed
you know i mean a lot of
so-called funny people are actually sad
on the inside that's just a
it's a trope i think you need to let it
out dj if you really want to be honest
you know i'm i'm a middle child um
my brother was is very smart my sister
is very beautiful and i was just sort of
like this nerdy accountant looking
kid and i guess i used comedy as a
defense mechanism and as a means of
armor to protect me i guess see now
that's funny that's funny because it's
true reza because because it's true
right maybe maybe a little bit more you
know patheticness and some more
like you know open tragedy i think i
think that would be good for your for
your career certainly our our scripts
would be funnier so you're saying you
want me to just be really really sad to
make your scripts funnier have a
miserable life just for the
14 15 seconds of the intro i mean i'm
miserable that that seems a little bit
extreme just sad sad but listen folks uh
we kid we we wanted to introduce you to
our wonderful producer dj labelle if
that's how you pronounce his name who is
both
profound
and funny
and delightful and thank you for keeping
our show humming along the way you do
and
this topic is near and dear to you right
dj yeah i mean listen i love comedy i
i've written for a bunch of really funny
people
and i just it's it's everything to me so
the fact that you guys are discussing
comedy with one of the great comedians
of the modern era who who do we have tig
notaro
oh my god holy [ __ ] i love tignataro
this is fantastic and who better to talk
about whether laughter is the best
medicine i mean
we're talking about a prime time emmy
and grammy-nominated
uh actress uh one of the funniest people
on the planet uh she's on star trek i
mean i've never known anyone on star
trek this it's like
this is the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me it's fantastic i couldn't
be happier she uh really broke open
uh in the comedy world when she did an
infamous comedy routine about her
survival of both breast cancer
which happened at approximately the same
time as the death of her mother
if you get a chance to listen to that
it's somewhere on the youtubes it's
absolutely brilliant and of course she's
got her own podcast because by law
every person on earth has to have a
podcast hers is called don't ask tig and
it's funny and good tig hi tig
fine this is so exciting like you have
to understand that um i don't really
know any celebrities and so it's very
exciting to have you here hey hey well
you don't you don't count that much rain
i mean i'm like half a celebrity anyway
all of this is to say that it's very
exciting very exciting to have you here
well i'm very happy to be here we're
having this whole conversation rain and
i were talking about
everyone's always like laughter's the
best medicine and and the tears of a
clown and uh you know how tragedy plus
time equals comedy and all these cliches
that we hear over and over again and we
thought um since i'm not very funny rain
not very funny um we should have
somebody funny
and um and you're funny so thank you
yeah there you go so i guess my first
question is when did you know you were
funny like how did that come about when
you suddenly were like you know what
maybe i'm funny well i i think i come
from a funny family
and so it was just kind of part of my
life and um
and a lot of characters are in my family
and uh
but i do remember
the first time where i really got
a kick out of myself
i was at lunch
i think i was in first grade
and a friend of mine
was going to open her
bag of fritos
and the little fritos bag was upside
down
and i remember saying
oh um
you better turn the bag
right side up or else you're gonna be
eating upside down fritos
yeah did it kill at the lunch table no
and this is this was like a couple of
years ago right it's just two years ago
today yeah
so a while back for soul pancake which
also helps produce this podcast i did a
short documentary called laughing
matters about the connection between
comedy and mental health and in it
sarah silverman said
100 of comedians become comedians
because somewhere in their childhood
they needed to be funny in order to
survive and i thought that was such a
great
quote is that true for you um i think it
has definitely helped my survival but
i think there's also
um something to being like i was saying
raised in a
you know
i think both things were happening
i was raised in a very
uh
funny
environment
and i think it it was easy to
i am very influenced by my mother i mean
she was the
i mean she was the famous funny one in
the family
uh and
i mean not
actually famous but
she was the funny one and
as
as life went on there were certainly
some horrible things
and my sense of humor was very helpful
but i
i think that's
what
i feel like with my life but i do think
that what sarah says
or said does apply
to a lot or most and maybe all i mean i
have no idea so you'd say was your
childhood really well balanced then you
didn't need comedy as some kind of
survival mechanism it was more just
kind of grocking your mother's
incredible sense of humor that was in no
that's what i'm saying is i was raised
in a a very
funny family an environment but also
there was horrific stuff
that i i think that my sense of humor
was helpful
in uh navigating and getting me through
did your family use humor to deal with
those kinds of things i mean when you
look back on it now obviously i mean
it's different when you were a kid
because you know you don't really know
what the hell is going on but when you
kind of think back on those
those dark times do you
have a memory of
um you know
the family this funny family that you
came from using humor in order to i
don't know sort of get through those
times or to even sometimes just turn
away from them no doubt
i mean
for sure
even now when i
talked to i was talking to
a really
great hilarious comedian earlier today
and i'm always surprised when i find out
when comedians still
feel like they can't
say certain things they might hurt
their
parents feelings or a sibling and
i just don't have that i mean to it to
be fair both my parents are dead at this
point but i do have a stepfather still
and i have a brother and i can't imagine
like censoring yourself
especially that was like
comedic
that they would be like oh you took that
too far
you know but also my stepfather's
favorite comedian is sarah silverman so
well there you have it so you've talked
before about uh in an interview we
looked at about your mother's comfort
with discomfort and
i love that phrase because i remember
tig i don't know you terribly well we've
crossed paths here and there we both
were on star trek discovery the first
time i i met you tig i don't know if you
remember this i asked you out of the
blue would you drive to riverside
california and do some comedy
uh at a comedy benefit for a a friend of
mine for a breast cancer uh
non-profit and i'll never forget
um i don't remember the exact words that
you used but
you're
there was a
a very interesting woman in the front i
think they were getting drunk on like
white wine spritzers or something like
that and
maybe her name was like barbara or
something like that and you you just
went in kind of sat on the edge of the
stage and you were very close to like
three feet from her and you were looked
in her eyes and you're like barbara
barbara barbara and it was so
so colossally uncomfortable and wrong
like no
you're not supposed to do this comedians
aren't supposed to be
three feet from someone gazing in their
eyes and pausing intermittably
and my wife was there with me and
the entire audience the backstage
howling laughter for 15 minutes as you
interacted with barbara i forget what
you did but and it was so delicious
completely improvised
and i that as soon as i read that quote
about your mother's comfort with
discomfort i was remembering you and
barbara in riverside california can you
tell me more about that
i don't know what it it really is so
influenced by my mother i i think
i was just
i was always watching my mother is very
into gilda radner and lucille ball and
joan rivers and um
uh
i i watched everything she watched i
wanted to be my mother you know that
yeah i just i was like i was so enamored
with her and uh the way she did things
and the way she walked in a room and the
way she
interacted with people and the shocking
things she said and
and um
and one of the things she always told me
was if anyone has a problem with me just
tell them to go to hell
and uh i don't know if i'm answering
your question right but i am thinking
about my mother's funeral
actually
when i was speaking at it i was
there was a priest standing next to me
and it wasn't we were in small town
mississippi my hometown my mother's
hometown
and it wasn't like the family priest it
was just a priest in the area and i was
talking about
that side of my mother and how she just
owned it and she wanted me to and
and um and i said you know she would
tell me to tell everyone to go to hell
and
and i
thought and i was verbalizing at my
mother's funeral how
i was concerned about talking about this
because the priest is standing
a couple of feet away to my left
and then i said at her funeral
i can i can imagine telling my mother
well
i don't know if it's appropriate to talk
about
all of these um
elements of your personality and how you
would tell me to tell everyone to go to
hell
because the priest is standing here and
then i could hear my mother saying
well if the priest has a problem with it
then he can go to hell
and um and i when i said that at my
mother's funeral the priest
started cracking up and it was such
an honest laugh that he had and it was
like
it was that moment of it was it was
uncomfortable and it was um
but it was just kind of having
faith and and hanging
hanging on a
on the edge of a moment and um and i
feel like that's what i watched my
mother do and
and you know you more more often times
than not you live through that
you know
rain uh i just got this comateer coffee
uh in the mail have you tried this thing
yet yes it is uh a delicious i'm telling
you this stuff provides this pour over
quality coffee without any of the fuss
or the mess or the excess time committee
sources their coffee from the world's
best locally owned specialty coffee
roasters their coffee obsessed team has
developed a new way to extract all the
nuances and aromas from each bean to
produce a phenomenal brew with one tenth
of the water comma tear arrives frozen
you just add six to eight ounces of hot
water to the frozen capsule for iced
coffee you just let the capsule melt
completely and pour the rich liquid over
ice water or milk
now you can make lattes and cappuccinos
without an espresso machine we got a
special offer for you just for our
listeners for a limited time
you can save 20 bucks
off your first order that's 10 free
cups it tastes just like that fancy pour
over coffee that you get at your coffee
shop
on your first order and the shipping is
always free but only when you visit
cometier.com
milkshake20 that's c-o-m-e-t-e-e-r.com
milkshake
20. look i'll be honest i was skeptical
about commentary coffee at first i mean
i'm like frozen coffee that's weird but
i'm telling you it is truly one of the
best if not the best cup of coffees i've
ever had so if you like coffee at all if
you're like me and rain you're a coffee
lover
i'm telling you this is a taste to
believe product that's commenter.com
milkshake20 you're going to save 20
bucks on your first order folks a new
day has arrived on earth for coffee
hey folks
if you're on a mission to be the best
gift giver ever this year it's never too
early to start crossing off your list so
whether you're shopping for mom or dad
or teenagers or in-laws or your best
friends or your neighbors or your
neighbor's dog
uncommon goods makes it easy to find
remarkable and truly original gifts for
anyone uncommon goods wants your holiday
season to be stress-free so check out
their selection of literally thousands
and thousands of items today you know i
have all these nieces and nephews and i
don't know what to buy my nieces and
nephews so i went on on common goods i
kind of punched in their age range
and i found so many cool things i bought
my niece this uh this like karaoke
microphone that she loves it's just like
look if you're somebody who doesn't know
what to get as a gift
the uncommon goods just kind of curates
all these great gifts depending on the
age that you're looking for the gender
that that you need uncommon goods looks
for products that are high quality
unique and often handmade or made in the
united states
they have the most meaningful out of the
ordinary gifts anywhere and with every
purchase you make at uncommon goods they
give back one dollar to a non-profit
partner of your choice
they've donated more than two and a half
million dollars to date so to get your
15 off your next gift go to
uncommongoods.com
milkshake this is 15 off folks
uncommongoods.com
milkshake for 15 off
don't miss out on this limited time
offer uncommon goods we are all out of
the ordinary
see this is really fascinating because
uh i love i love your your stand up and
your performances and so much of it is
about
being comfortable with discomfort right
talking about
uh like your cancer diagnosis you know
the death of your your mother you know
just being very
open
and willing to make the audience squirm
if necessary
um and then
sort of hitting them right at that
moment you know with with the punch line
um
and i wonder like how much it because
part of that performance part of how you
know you do the things that you do i
think is baked into
um what
humor actually is what laughter does for
us right there's all this
study and research about how
the purpose of laughter
evolutionarily speaking
um is precisely to break tension right
there's this
uh
freud line he says that humor
is the highest of the psyches defense
mechanism
and that
evolutionarily speaking the reason you
know that we laugh the reason that there
are you know jokes and humor and stuff
like that is because
it turns
anxiety into pleasure
right so in those moments of tension
between two people or between two
communities or whatever the case may be
when it could lead to something ugly
that we're primed to laugh at at the
smallest thing
and what that does is it releases the
tension it keeps us from you know
bopping each other over the head with
whatever club we have
uh and and we continue to evolve as as
human beings and
so much of that i see in your
sort of stand-up and your performances
and and it comes from your mother i
guess i i believe so i mean
i really i have so many influences but i
would say she is by far
or she was by far the the biggest
it's become a kind of cliche this whole
thing about um
the intersection between comedy and
darkness and
and you know their entire documentaries
and books written about um comics or
funny people who were actually masking
you know great darkness or sadness
um
and
i just wonder like you know
do you feel as though
that
is something that's necessary like this
mental struggle
something that is necessary to truly be
funny in in in the kind of funny what i
mean the kind of funny in that involves
really making connections with
um you know an audience and with people
i don't think so at all i think it's one
way of connecting with people
um
but i also
don't i just don't
you know a lot of people do feel like oh
comedians are
are depressed or they they're dark or
they're toxic or they're miserable or
um all of those things and it is true
for pl plenty of them
but
the majority of people alive on this
planet
are toxic
or depressed
miserable
uh all of those things uh your family
members your next-door neighbors your
the mail carrier
um and then you know people
talk about musicians or
or painters or poets that they're
they're all miserable and they're
suffering and it's like
they are
expressing themselves publicly
so that's why they seem like they are
and it's also i think
frequently about um
the idea that rock stars
always die in plane crashes
it's like
no just a good one no yeah sure but also
a lot of dentists
die in plane crashes it's tragic it's
tragic but they're not public figures
so if we started clocking every dentist
that died in a plane crash we would be
like oh gosh i hope dad my dad's a
dentist he's about to go on a flight
this is i'm scared every time he flies
you know it's just when your public
figure
what you're doing
or how you're dying
or you know what i mean it's like i
totally get it the counterpoint to that
and i don't disagree actually the
counterpoint to that is
you know there are these studies like
there was this 2014 study that was done
that found that comedians
don't live as long as less funny people
which first of all i think that's
hilarious i think it's funny that like
uh some some like researcher somewhere
was like i'm gonna divide
my test subjects into funny and not
funny and then figure out
who dies first so comedians that are
less
popular live a little bit longer
so there was a study in 2014 and it was
a study of comedians and circus clowns
and apparently
this study which
was about comedians and circus clowns
found that uh comedians and circus
clowns
tend to be
more
um self-critical and negative towards
themselves
than people who again people who are not
funny even people who are performers but
who aren't
uh comedic
performers
and then there was this other guy
this is a
oxford psychologist named gordon
claridge
and
he did it by the way who are these
people who keep doing these studies on
comedians well i wanted to talk about
old gordon clarage our friend retired
university of oxford psychologist he
studied comedians and he found that they
have they seem to have two
competing personality traits
introverted
and hedonia an inability to feel
pleasure
and extroverted impulsiveness
and which is similar
to actors so they were asocial and a
little emotionally flat often suffering
from clinical depression but at the same
time that part of their personality
split with their impulsive
extroverted tendencies and that this
kind of dichotomy
inherent inside them perhaps gave them a
funny perspective on the world and i
wanted to talk about that because i'll
just share personally for me i'm now i'm
not a stand-up like tig and i i really
admire stand-up comics i am i do not
have the ability to
write jokes and tell stories in such a
way where i can captivate an audience
for 20 minutes or 45 minutes or an hour
and a half or what have you i don't have
those skills i just
play weird characters
but
um
some of the characters i've played have
been considered funny and i do for me i
think
i so didn't fit in as a as a child
that and i so longed to fit in that the
source of the comedy that i'm able to
find and the characters that i play
uh is that kind of disconnect between a
longing to fit in and an inability to
fit in and that just kind of milking my
natural
awkwardness so i want to applaud gordon
because i i would feel that yeah i'm i
suffer from depression i can be a little
uh emotionally flat and i can also be
impulsive i think he kind of described
me
uh can you relate to any of this tig or
does this
this shoe doesn't fit no it certainly
does um
i've i've had depression at different
points in my life um
more so when i was
i would say a teenager and um
early 20s
um
but i've had
bouts of not feeling great emotionally
but
what i really relate to is my mother not
my mother but stephanie my wife
she jokingly she had read somewhere that
i don't know if it was my
birth sign or
something
in the stars that described my
personality
um
a way to describe me the opposite way to
describe me is
yeah this can wait
um and so uh
anytime i do something and i do it
quickly
after i decide
i'm very like here's what i'm thinking
and then i move i make a move she always
says
yeah this can wait
um so i don't know
i guess that's
you know along the lines of impulsive
well is that part of the because the
other thing that this uh this oxford uh
um dude said is that
comedy then becomes a form of
self-medication
for people who do it for a living right
that it's like
it's part of the healing process and
you've actually talked about this too
you know when when you started talking
uh in your stand-up routine about your
cancer diagnosis i mean you you would i
i'd read somewhere that you had talked
about that as a kind of um like
self-medication like a way to
to connect with the audience and create
a kind of community to be understood
um in a sense you know to feel
less isolated less alone in in that
moment so that that's kind of
self-medication isn't it there have been
times in my life
whether it's
having cancer or or losing somebody
close to me and having to do a show
and
just for that moment in time
being able to feel
just a little better for a little while
and uh
and then of course you go back to
reality and it's uh
it's exactly where things left off but
but yeah it's
it's it's a drug that carries you
through
about an hour
hour and a half
well what's even i think what's even
more fascinating about it is that it's
not
like it's not fake i think i think maybe
some people would say oh sure you laugh
about something because you don't want
to face it or you don't want to deal
with it
um
that it's you know a way of of ignoring
um any kind of trauma or tragedy but
that's not what the research shows the
research shows that it actually
does
lessen the tragedy like the ability to
laugh at something particularly in a
group
right the ability to take a tragedy
or even actually it can be any sort of a
moral behavior of any kind as well as a
tragedy that
joking about it in a group
actually
can sort of remove
some of the tragic
elements out of it because what it does
is it says to the to the group
that um
we all share the same point of view
right that that we're that we're kind of
united by a
common way of looking at this particular
thing you know and it could be
you know heart like it could be a
horrifying thing that we're all laughing
about but the laughter
does have the ability to actually lessen
the trauma and the tragedy it's not just
our imagination like it's not just this
ephemeral thing where for a little while
you feel good about it but it's not it
hasn't changed anything
i mean the research shows that it
actually does change things
i i believe that it changes things i
think it's also like um
there's something to
what i've
been trying to learn with comedy is
in my relationship
when there's any sort of tension
we make a joke to break the tension and
it's helpful because it
creates a connection and
allows us to talk about something and i
think that that's kind of
what needs to happen with the follow
through
after you
you get that little
rush
with
the laughter is that you have to kind of
do that follow through
that is
another level of of working on things
because like in in a marriage you can't
just
have
tension or in a friendship have tension
and make a joke and then laugh at the
joke and then never go back to the issue
right yeah yeah so i recently produced
this uh little video
where
it the whole idea is about climate
change and it's for the ted conferences
and they're doing a conference on
climate change and so i asked comedians
this question is there any comedy to be
mined from climate change is there
anything funny about climate change and
tig you were a part of this and had a
really
a couple of funny really great
observations
in your inimitable style and um
but it's interesting because the seven
minute video
ends up being really
moving and and kind of affecting and sad
and yes it's funny throughout but
watching these great comedians
struggle you know conan o'brien or al
madrigal or ed helms just struggle to
uh find something funny about climate
change and and these feeble attempts at
jokes um it it it really is a
way more affecting than watching some
kind of lecture about climate change uh
so i hope that this video
once we get it all finished and get it
out into the world uh affects people but
what was it like for you trying to make
a joke about climate change first of all
and
you know are there things that are not
funny or things that we should not
joke about i know those are two very
different topics
i am so
uh
upset and terrified by climate change
that
yeah i don't find anything
funny but i think it's only because
i just haven't found the angle
however
i don't i don't think there is anything
out of bounds in comedy and it's because
you know people get upset and say oh you
can't in fact i had a podcast like a
decade ago
and there was a guest that came on and
he was talking about how
cancer was not funny
and you can't make a joke about it
and i had already
done my show
and he was not familiar
with me
and i was i was saying you so you're
telling me you can't there's no
situation where you can make any sort of
joke he's like no
i've lost people to cancer and i was
like i understand it's like but is there
was there possibly an angle
or a person or a way and he's no
absolutely not
and so that was like this amusing moment
silently that i was having that i knew
the listeners of my podcast would would
be having you know
they'd enjoy hearing but
um
i feel like the problem is like this guy
was doing on my podcast is
imagining
that it's
haha
you have cancer
that it's something
it's something so
obvious or stupid
or
um
hacky whatever it is
and they
they're not
allowing for the the comedian or the
moment or the angle
the perspective that would surprise you
and
come at it in a way that's not gonna
offend you that's going to
break the tension
and um and make people
laugh i mean their laugh might
be
you know accompanied by a face
expression of like oh
oh
no
you know but it's the tension breaker
like like freud said
yeah and and i think it's not fair to
assume what the angle is going to be
so
everything that's going on today tig
mental health epidemic we talked about
climate change political disunity and
hatred racism income inequality
what's the role of the comic
um
you know
i mean throughout time we've you know
some of the greatest american comedy
came out of
you know the disruptions you know of the
of the uh you know the vietnam war
richard pryor dealt with racism
um lenny bruce
yeah kind of broke a lot of shibboleths
about american culture in the 50s and
60s
um but today it's just it's so daunting
um
does the comic play an important role in
what's happening right now
i mean always i think their important
role is to keep going and to keep the
conversations going to keep
people engaged and
considering different points of view and
uh
but also
allowing themselves and allowing comedy
to evolve and
and change and um
i mean everything has to and uh
i think that
it's
it's it's like being on stage as a
comedian
you have to you can't run off stage when
it gets hard
you have to
you have to keep going and you have to
that didn't work you find a different
angle and you you just keep going and i
think that
people are going to appreciate that more
than than running off the stage the
actual stage or
the stage of life
one of the
things that i had no idea doing the
office was
just how much laughter meant to people i
just didn't really think about it i was
just like well i'll just play this weird
character and get a good paycheck and
hey i can buy a house
um
but so many years afterwards you know so
many so much gratitude and thanks for
the laughter that the show provided and
how healing that was like our my parents
were getting a divorce and this we
watched your show and my you know my
sister was sick and we watched your show
i was really depressed and watched your
show and it brought so much so there's
also that service component isn't there
yeah
and it's weird because
i used to not really
understand when people
would say that i'd get off stage i'd be
like i have to tell you you helped me
through a really hard time or and i'd be
like oh cool thanks you know glad that
oh i'm so glad and i was i was glad to
hear it but i
didn't really think about it i didn't
really
really think about
that
and um
and i think music
does that for me
and
when i
went through a hard time
and um
and really relied on on music i i
thought about that and
i was like oh right that really did help
me through
that time period
and um
yeah so it's it is a real thing and
and it's it's nice to
to be doing something that is
a service you know or of service to
people
this is really just uh some help that i
need to because rain has been completely
useless in this like
can anyone make me a red shirt on star
trek because i i've tried rain but he's
like you know
he doesn't have a lot of power over
there i don't have a lot of pull yeah i
i'm afraid i don't either see what you
can do maybe the two of you together i
just feel like i would die so well i
would i would
i mean
let's do it right now for those watching
on youtube
uh tig could you shoot reza with a
phaser yeah i'll be right now i'll be
like a baby i'll be a bad alien let's
see what happens hey human
see that that's terrible how could you
not hire me yeah i don't think people
would take our recommendation on
anything again and i want to say and i
know i told you this rain i think over
email
but
my kids
love the office
they're fine
they've loved it since they were three
what
[Laughter]
they have loved it since they were three
and stephanie and i
exactly the way you reacted we're both
like
what are they getting what what do they
what is happening
well tig every show we do a lightning
round
of life's big questions some absurd
questions thrown in for good measure
uh so we would like to hit you with some
lightning round questions just respond
first thing that comes into your head
uh what recharges your soul i enjoy
going home to mississippi with my family
i love going home
what skill do you wish you had uh i wish
that i could play the piano what is one
eye-opening experience every person
should have heartbreak
what's one thing you would change about
yourself i wish i had never smoked a
cigarette
name something a lot of people like but
you personally can't stand
animal products
what book change your life you know very
recently i read a book called um
and i loved it and i highly
highly recommend it it's called the way
of integrity
and it is
it's so incredible it's just
really all about
getting to the most honest point
that you can get in your life
that sounds like a great book for reza
yeah
i could definitely use some integrity if
you could have coffee with 15 year old
tignotaro what would you tell yourself i
would say
you're not going to believe this
but you are going to be
on what seems like
the absolute wrong path
for about
25 years
and you're going to find
that that
wrong path
was exactly the right path
to drop you off
in the perfect spot
to begin the life that you will not
even
believe
that you have that you get to have you
won't believe it
well we talked about your awesome twins
what's one tip that you can give parents
that would help with their children's
happiness
well you know
my stepfather
didn't really take much of an interest
in me
in my life or understand me or
encourage me
to do
my passions and
[Music]
all of that kind of stuff and then when
my mother died and he's a very reserved
up first buttoned up person and
when my mother died
he and i drove away from the cemetery in
mississippi and he was crying and it was
the first time in my life i'd ever seen
him cry
and he said and i was i was stunned and
he apologized
for having never supported me or
understood me or gotten to know me
and he said because he had told me that
i shouldn't do comedy that i should get
you know a real job and that i was
wasting my intelligence
and it hurt my feelings but he
apologized for that after my mother's
funeral
and he said you know i've
i've realized
that it's not the child's job
to teach the parent who they are
it's the parents job to learn who their
child is
and
i was so blown away
that that thought lived in his head or
was born
in his
heart or soul like i couldn't even
believe it you know
and it's something that i try to
remember
with my children
is
i can have my ideas of what i
think they're gonna be or what i think i
want but they just have to tell me
who they are
here we are
talking about comedy
and we have one of the world's most
famous comedians on the show and and i
feel like tears are welling up in my
eyes
um what the hell is going on what the
[ __ ] is going on well blame it on my
stepfather because it was his it's his
words and his thoughts and
his awakening you know
and then
finally what is your life's big question
how
do
we let
go
how do i let go how do people let go
will you come back on the show and we
can do a life's big question on how do
we let go
yeah i would love to
it's my
it's my
you know
it's every it's it's so helpful in every
aspect of life
in in a good way of like you just gotta
let go and then you also like i gotta
let go of this
you know it's like all of that like how
do you do it
technotaro thank you so much for uh
diving deep with us on the milkshake
team this has been such a pleasure
thanks for having me i was very excited
and i i think max will have many
questions about this this experience
that i just had
[Music]
how great is tignataro incredible
conversation be honest with me was i i
was awestruck wasn't i i i wasn't at my
best that was the most like star struck
i've ever seen you it's weird it's weird
there's something i just i just love her
you are like a giddy school girl meeting
what was the monkeys in 1972. so i was
like davey jones i love you davey
mickey
mike yes i do know all the names of the
monkeys davey mickey mike peter boom
take that but i was really struck at how
uh
moving
so much of uh what she said was it was
really um it really uh
was i was very touched you know and
that's what's so interesting to me when
you when you
when you start to get into comedy
it actually starts to become
very serious i think there's something
there's a deep connection there between
the stuff that makes us laugh is the
stuff that makes us human you know and
you can't separate the two when you're
talking about
the importance of comedy the evolution
of comedy why we're funny why we rely on
comedy
we're getting to some really meaty heavy
human stuff yeah and i and i totally get
where she's coming from with that whole
point that she makes about how
you know let's not make a big deal about
the fact that comedians are particularly
tragic people or that they are deeply
you know sad people we're all tragic
we're all sad your dentist is sad and
depressing but he just cleans teeth for
a living and i totally get that at the
same time though
maybe what it is is that
the drive
to
stand in front of an audience that's
judging you
right
uh
that
to to then
appear before them and to
use something so profound
uh and and so effective as comedy
in order
to talk about tragic issues the things
that you're dealing with the things that
people are dealing with like there's a
certain
mindset i think a certain psychology
that's required to do that well so maybe
it's not just that like
sad people become comedians or like all
comedians are sad but maybe it's more
that
comedians have this ability
because they themselves have learned how
to self-medicate
right with humor
that they have the ability to like you
know some kind of pharmacist to hand out
that medication to everybody else
right to make all of us feel better
for a little while at least or to at the
very least look differently at you know
the issues that we are we are facing um
whether it is like race issues or
climate or whatever the case may be
um
and to
uh
tap in to that part of us
that is looking for something to break
the tension right you brought up earlier
and and and i love it when you bring up
this concept of like evolutionarily
why is there humor
in our consciousness in in the human
psyche in character why is there humor
why is there just not humor i mean
wolverines don't have humor right it's
like and they're doing just fine yeah i
think i think wolverines are doing just
fine somebody find out if how wolverines
are doing but i think you know it it
helps us survive it helps us survive i
think so you know it whatever it is it
breaks tension it's a coping mechanism
it's a response to trauma it connects us
it bonds us
it helped us survive maybe human beings
would not be where we are today
on the threshold of apocalypse without
humor and hopefully humor can carry us
forward through some very
assuredly difficult uh decades and
probably centuries ahead
what do you guys think uh dear listeners
look we always end every one of these
podcasts by asking you what you think
but this time honestly i really really
want to know like
do you have a story about
dealing with tragedy with humor do you
have a story about
how
humor or laughter
um
healed you i mean like literally healed
you i don't mean like made you feel good
for a little while but like
fixed you know a problem do you have a
story
of
um going to see a comedian and and
having you know your
your
perspective changed let us know
well folks as you know we say it all the
time if you rate and review us and ask
your life's big question uh in the
review
uh
section uh and we like your question who
knows we might ask you to come on the
pod and and uh ask it to us directly you
get to meet
uh two
equally famous celebrities uh rain
wilson
uh
i believe actor i think is that what you
do rain i sometimes i forget a little
bit i dabble occasionally when i'm not
unemployed this week we got a really
interesting one uh from a listener by
the name of luke weeks who's a real
person and not just a fake villain on a
cw show so what's the question luke
i had a dream about three months ago and
i left this voicemail that what if it
was possible what if we're viewing
energy completely wrong
and what if the true way to travel
between galaxies
is inter-dimensional
so ditch the fossil fuels ditch the
traditional means but an
inter-dimensional way to travel
just just so we understand uh because
you know we're rayne and i are obviously
very very smart we're experts in
astrophysics as well but you can
understand why other people might be
confused by your question not us
obviously well because
the distance between planets is so great
right like we're never going to be able
to
take a trip between here and like
another galaxy so we've got to figure
something else out we have to start this
conversation by by talking about
you know the multiverse first right
because that's a that's a topic that uh
rain and i have discussed before on this
show this idea that
our universe is not the only universe
there are other
universes kind of layered upon
ours uh it's a very fun uh part of you
know the
marvel universe uh and it makes for
great movies there is literally zero
scientific evidence zero observable
evidence whatsoever for a multiverse
fundamentally the multiverse is more
than anything else
the answer to the question
why is there life in our universe like
why because things appear you know
things had to work out in exactly the
right way
for us to be able to be here to say
is why is there life in the universe and
the answer
that is often provided is that
there are you know infinite number of
universes and and in an infinite number
of universes in one of them
things ha things must have worked out
perfectly so that we exist and we can
answer this question obviously that's
not a that's not what we would refer to
as scientific evidence
uh
but let's say there is a multivator okay
let's just begin with there is a
multiverse
how do
we experience the other dimensions rain
you've been you've been to other
dimensions reza you're so good at
talking out of your ass thank you no
idea what you're saying thank you thank
you this is i have a degree in talking
out of my ass
an advanced degree
i think there was probably about 78 of
our listening audience that was like oh
yeah he's making some really valuable
and interesting and good points there
multiverse
sounds like he knows what he's talking
about luke we have no one that sounds
great we don't know he's a he has a phd
in sociology and religious studies and
i'm an actor on a sitcom i don't know
do you have any ideas luke about
interdimensional travel or multiverses
yeah i've had these weird dreams i'm i'm
thinking it might have something to do
with string theory
and the thought of the space between
particles right that scientists still
really don't know like what is that
space
that scientists are still trying to
figure out and splitting atoms and
i think if we can ever split an atom
then we'll probably open up the
multiverse and
maybe i will say this that uh i have
heard it said
that it's possible to maybe use black
holes
to travel between
uh universes there is the whole problem
of you know
like going through a black they're going
through the black hole part that that's
that's still to be to be said
mcconaughey do it he did and it worked
for him so there you go uh luke i wish
we could have been of more help wait i
haven't i have a question for luke hold
on rain let's let's take this to the to
the next level if you were able to go
through a black hole and go into another
dimension
and meet the other luke weeks
would you kill that luke weeks and
absorb his energy i think he would kill
me
[Laughter]
but i do i do one thing i do agree on
luke is that we need to in terms of
science uh be thinking in much kind of
broader terms rather than like a jet
fuel propelled
metal
you know rocket ship going from earth to
another planet um you know at a you know
a couple hundred thousand miles an hour
that's just not gonna cut it so we have
to be
looking at other options if we if
interstellar travel is uh in our future
so
you know good luck with that everyone
out there listening who knows anything
about that because it's not me and reza
thanks for being on the show thanks for
your kind words for me let me tell you
what bothers me about that conversation
with luke is that
he revealed to all of our audiences that
we're full of [ __ ] like all this time
we've been hiding that fact i know we
had them fooled
so want more of life's big questions
find us on social please at reza aslan
and rayne wilson on twitter at
metamilkpodcast and instagram
milkshake let us know your life's big
questions and uh like the man said we
might explore them on a future episode
remember to follow rate and review
review us please metaphysical milkshake
on apple podcasts please and wherever
else you get your goddamn podcasts we uh
we like some good reviews and we would
love to hear from you and connect with
you
on the old reviewing
boards
is that what they're called reviewing
boards
you've never been on the internet have
you you can also subscribe to the
metaphysical milkshake youtube channel
and watch us have these conversations
in sterling 4k
digital quality thanks everyone see you
next week see
ya metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by justin kyle original music is
composed by jeff tang
you are a cruise ship comedian it was
kind of the early days of my career
where it's it's oh cool i'd go on a
cruise and go to these different cities
and
you know and um
and i didn't think about how then you're
stuck and with the people that didn't
laugh at your jokes the night before
you're in the buffet line with them
exactly
and i wasn't at the point where i could
be helicoptered in and helicoptered out
you weren't at the helicopter stage no
you weren't in kevin hart territory i
was at the uh
the buffet
phase of my career
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you